and the more diversity that you have in
your organization the more likely you
are to understand different markets
different target audiences right that
can lead into new business development
opportunities
a better outreach in your marketing
as well as better customer experiences
because you have people internally who
can
understand your customer base and and
serve them more effectively
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today we're talking about
inclusion equity and belonging with
cynthia oh young the vice president of
inclusion equity and belonging for robin
hood she drives the company's approach
to enhancing its culture of diversity
and inclusion
cynthia is also the founder of breaking
glass forms where she develops
strategies to accelerate more diverse
leaders and inclusive organizations a
recognized diversity leader cynthia was
named to entrepreneur magazine's 100
women of impact in 2021 cynthia serves
on the board of directors for ability
path a non-profit dedicated to
empowering people with special needs to
achieve their full potential
i i really appreciate you coming here
and you know this show is about
leadership and all its facets and a lot
of times we have here you know leaders
from different tech companies and
different verticals uh you're vice
president of inclusion equity and
belonging within robin hood but beyond
that you've you're you're playing a
really active role within the tech
ecosystem when it comes to diversity
inclusion equity and belonging a founder
and ceo of breaking glass forums
you're on board directors of ability
path and nonprofit and you're the author
of a new book all are welcome how to
build a real workplace culture of
inclusion that delivers results and so
i'm really excited to chat with you over
these 20 minutes about you know your
experience about you know building a
real workplace culture that delivers
results when it comes to inclusion
equity and diversification so thank you
very very much for being here
i am thrilled to be able to chat about
this topic anywhere anytime
well
i'd like to start with you by really
understanding you know what it means to
create a real workplace culture that
delivers results because the terms
diversity equity inclusion it gets
thrown around a lot especially in the
last few years and i'm often left
thinking okay how do we actually get
this to tangible results within
organizations so perhaps you can help
help me sort through this
yeah you know it takes a lot of
intention
and hard work to get there you know i
think that people have to really
understand all the nuances behind the
differences between diversity equity
inclusion and belonging where diversity
is really about representation equity is
about making sure that that
representation has equal opportunities
and access to all those opportunities
inclusion is really about
making sure that you're able to leverage
that diversity in your organization to
its fullest potential and belonging is
that sense of connection that people
have to your company so that they'll
want to perform
at their best and so
companies really have to focus on all
four facets
uh of these things to really be able to
deliver more innovation more creativity
higher performance as a culture
um mckinsey and many other
companies have done studies that show
that organizations that have more
diverse leadership
um and more diverse teams
have better financial performance as an
organization so i don't see why any
organization wouldn't focus on these uh
these things around diversity equity
inclusion and belonging if they want to
be effective and successful and position
themselves for growth in the future
fantastic so we're going to get in a
second to some some tangible things that
organizations and and leaders can do to
to to be effective at this mission but
before that going back to these reports
that you're mentioning and understanding
the advantages of creating a diversified
executive leadership team
within organizations and and workforce
in general why in your opinion is it
that having a more diverse workforce
increases productivity and at the end
financial results for business
on a very practical level
well if you have more diversity in your
organization you are going to have
different perspectives that give you
more innovative ideas right
and
studies also show that when you're able
to leverage all of these different
perspectives in an effective way it
actually leads to better decision making
as well
and the more diversity that you have in
your organization the more likely you
are to understand different markets
different target audiences right that
can lead into new business development
opportunities
a better outreach in your marketing
as well as better customer experiences
because you have people internally who
can understand your customer base and
and serve them more effectively than if
you didn't have some of those
perspectives represented inside your
company so these are all things that are
all you know that lead to those better
business results but you have to be able
to
reflect that customer base that you have
and externally and internally as well
and you have to provide an environment
in which um that talent that you're
attracting and that represents all of
these different diverse backgrounds um
can really feel like they have the
opportunity to thrive right and so that
means making sure that you're hiring
from an inclusive lens making sure that
you're promoting people and advancing
their careers
with equal access to those different
opportunities and
not letting bias kind of get in the way
of your perceptions of their potential
and it means really being able to create
that uh an environment where people feel
like they have a voice and that they can
contribute that different perspective to
all of the things that i mentioned
earlier so that you can then drive those
results that you're looking to
um to progress around whether that is
you know
stronger sales more innovation um you
know again expanding your marketplace
and expanding your market share like all
of those things um can come as a result
of having more diversity in your
organization
right and i particularly love you know
what you mentioned
um a little while ago
talking about how you know beyond just
being able to foster more innovation and
more creativity different points of view
within the organization you're also much
better just you're much more able to
serve you know a diversified customer
base you know in a globalized world
where tech companies are creating
offerings for for you know people of all
cultures and geographical locations you
know having a more diversified
leadership team allows you to to
understand the customers better and to
cater to them especially as you know
there's different different you know
cultures and different understandings of
how their consumer behavior is
interacting with the product now talking
specifically about your book all are
welcome how to build a real workplace
culture of inclusion that delivers
results
now we're talking more tangibly about
how to go about doing that right so what
are some things that you've learned
throughout your career
that that shine light on on being able
to do what we're talking about but you
know doing it successfully
yeah i mean everything that you need to
do spans from you know your entire
employee life cycle right so from hiring
to development to retention
and like all of these things are things
that that uh have very specific
strategies
that companies can use and
in support of diversity equity inclusion
belonging so you know if we take hiring
as a good example any company that is
doing any significant amount of hiring
we'll look at that as a lever to pull to
drive uh greater diversity in their
organization right um and so you have to
look at every piece of that process of
hiring as its own sort of stage where
bias can be mitigated right so think
about like
job descriptions even the process of
writing a job posting
um can have uh really um profound
implications to
who is actually attracted to your
company right who will actually apply if
you use a very gendered
terminology in your job description as
an example you know lots of job
descriptions will say things like oh we
we want people who are rock stars um who
are ninjas you know who are work hard
play hard like all of these types of
phrases are very masculine in nature and
that will tend to turn off women from
applying to your role similarly there's
research that says that you know women
will apply to roles if they meet
only if they need a hundred percent of
the requirements listed versus men will
only will apply if they only meet 60
right and so that will skew your
applicant pool as well and that's a very
tangible um and concrete way if people
can really um be thoughtful about what
they're putting into job descriptions
and thoughtful about what really they
are requiring of folks versus what's
like a preferred qualification for a
role um that can make a difference in
the
talent pool that actually applies and
then gets considered and then moves
through your hiring pipeline right so
that's just one example of a way to
mitigate bias to to really be thoughtful
about how you hire
um people from more diverse backgrounds
and i can go on and on right so there's
like interviewing and making sure that
you have consistent standards for
interviewing and evaluation criteria for
assessing a candidate then there's like
offers and making sure that you actually
customize your benefits and appeal to
that particular candidate who may have
very specific needs and wants right um
around their benefits and so all of
these things are ways that people need
to really start to think about being
thoughtful in their hiring process to
really drive hiring for more diversity
in in their companies
so what i'm hearing is that there's a
lot of intentionality that needs to come
into play when when in the hiring
pipeline and it starts from you know the
basic format of a job description all
the way to the interviews and the hiring
and and it goes all the way to the
complexity of the of the benefits and
the structure of the benefits and
compensation that that you offer that
that obviously needs to be different it
needs to be considerate of the different
needs of of different people in
different situations and and and i like
the idea of now transitioning to
okay so now we we've been intentional
and we've built an organization
where the hiring is you know promoting
towards equity diversity and inclusion
but now we're running a company now
we're in the day-to-day of building
products making decisions within the
organizations what are things that i as
a young ceo needs need to take into
account as i'm you know running the
company and shaping the way we make
decisions
yeah great question um so you know at
any leader
of a team or a company right needs to be
thoughtful about the culture that
they're creating where employees can
have a voice and feel like they have
enough psychological safety to use that
voice right um because you want to be
able to surface new ideas you want to be
able um to have people feel
um free to express their opinions um and
and share different perspectives and you
know challenge each other right because
it's through challenge and debate very
often that we get to better decisions
right um you know i think that uh there
there's always cases of
of people being like you know seeing
seeing as yes people right like if
you're if you're a leader and everyone
is always saying yes to you i don't
think that that necessarily leads to
better decisions around better products
and how you better serve your customers
right you have to have some of that
challenge and debate in order to do that
people need to feel like they can they
can do that without any sort of
repercussion right um and and that's
where the inclusion piece and belonging
pieces really come in because you know
you you run a meeting and you want
people to be able to share their
opinions but you know if the if there's
like two people in the room who are like
the loudest people in the room that
drowns out everyone else and you don't
take the time to be intentional about
drawing out some of those more quiet
voices in different ways right
then you're missing that great
perspective and an opportunity to
leverage that in your decisions so
um being very mindful about the culture
that you're creating and how you amplify
different voices
um and provide channels for creativity
and innovation to surface in that way
are going to be the ways that you
actually create better products um there
is sort of a
a concept that we use in uh diversity
equity inclusion work very often that
says when you design for um
your sort of edge cases then you're
designing for everybody right and you're
making something much more effective in
the process
um and and so you know the more that you
can think about like what are those
lived experiences those marginalized
experiences that you can design and
develop for and serve then you're
actually going to create better product
better
services right for everyone that you
serve and and i think that's a key
mantra to keep in mind as any leader
fantastic and now we're at the retention
piece right so so we've worked on on
providing a platform for voices to
surface and for and and being
intentional with that just as we were
intentional with a with a hiring process
but now we you brought up this question
of retention which is also a factor we
need to take into account as leaders
when it comes to inclusion
diversification and equity
yeah retention matters because um here's
the thing right where what so many
companies are trying to increase their
diverse representation in inside them
and
and so they spend a lot of effort like
hiring people from different backgrounds
into their companies but they're not
spending as much effort to keep
the diverse talent that they have right
and so
oftentimes you'll see
people leaving the company at the same
rates that they're coming in and
therefore your representation doesn't
actually move right
so it's sort of like then it becomes a
zero-sum game and that's not what any of
us wants you have to look at how are you
actually retaining
that diverse talent in addition to
hiring and that's you know arguably one
of the most important things because
then you're you're not wasting your
effort bringing them in right um
but what is it where's the pitfall when
it comes to this
to the retention where's the challenge
why do
people tend to to leave at the rate of
coming in especially when we're talking
about the diversification
yeah that's where the concept of
inclusion and belonging really
matters right if people don't feel like
they can grow
and learn and develop inside your
company um that is the number one reason
that they tend to leave right and people
leave for a whole host of other reasons
things like compensation or a lack of
benefits or you know um
feeling like
there's like just a bigger better
opportunity elsewhere right but to the
extent that you can engage people and
help them feel like super connected and
therefore more loyal to your company um
and that can take the um
take the form of just even having
friends at your company and companies
like gallup have proven that just you
know having a circle of support uh
whether that's like a best friend at
work or a community like an employee
resource group that you belong to
and or a connection to your team and
your manager and really feeling like a
strong connection
and support from that team
can make a huge difference in people's
intent to stay at a company so
that's those are the things that you
want to focus on you want to make sure
that your managers are capable and
inclusive leaders and know how to coach
and guide um
the people on their team um no matter
what kind of background they have right
the ability to work across difference
the ability to
um develop that difference and to learn
from that difference and leverage it
like these are all things that will help
people to really want to stay
at the company and give them you know
and hopefully do the best work of their
lives
i love it and something i can't believe
that another 20 minutes went by so fast
it's one of the fastest 20 minutes that
i've had gone by and i have so many more
questions
and then trying to understand you know
where your your passion is coming from
and your personal experiences that that
have shaped these insights but i'm gonna
have to leave that to another episode
and i really appreciate you taking the
time to to to be on the show and to
share your perspective and i can't wait
to to also read the book which just i
believe came out very recently in
january right and so really uh
congratulations on that and thank you
for the amazing work that you're doing
and and i hope that that it will make a
positive impact on a lot of leaders in a
lot of organizations and obviously then
these are the organizations that they're
beyond shaping their own workforce
they're shaping the products that we are
using in our day-to-day uh which has
just as big an impact on diversity and
inclusion within our society beyond just
the the tech workforce so cynthia thank
you very very much for being here
thank you so much michael i really
enjoyed the conversation and i'd love to
continue it in the future i appreciate
it